This magical glowing mixture is very strange,
because it handles like pizza dough, but the
instant you stop moving, it liquifies and
melts into a glowing goo. In this project
you'll see how to turn your ordinary garden
potatoes, into this fluorescent magical mud.
Let's get started by grabbing a big bag of
potatoes, and washing the outsides so they're
all nice and clean. Now we need to chop these
up into the smallest pieces possible so, for
convenience, I'm using a food processor. If
you don't have one, you can always chop your
potatoes with a knife and cutting board. When
you've got your potatoes reduced to tiny bits,
slide them all into a large mixing bowl, and
pour in enough hot water to cover them completely.
We'll need to stir this around for a few minutes,
and you may have noticed the water turning
red, and that's completely normal. Now let's
grab a strainer and another large bowl, so
we can separate the potato water from the
chunks, then watch closely as something incredible
begins to happen. After about 10 minutes,
you can see a strange white layer appears
at the bottom of the bowl. Now if we try pouring
everything out, you can see this new white
layer, amazingly, stays in the bottom.  The goop is a little bit dirty, so to
clean it, let's mix in a bit of fresh water,
and pour it into a tall thin container, like
a glass or a jar. When the lid is on tight,
let's just shake it all up again, then let
it sit for another 10 minutes. Once again,
you can see it separates into layers, and
this time, almost all the impurities are collected
in the middle. Now check this out. If we quickly
dump out the water, it takes most of the impurities
with it, leaving us with a very clean, and
magical substance. It kind of looks like milk,
but if you try stirring it around, you can
see it behaves very strangely. Now if this
goo is left out for a day or two, you can
see it will crumble into a powder without
much effort at all. And that's exactly what
we need, to take this to the next level, and
add the glow. The magic happens with a bottle
of tonic water, because it contains quinine.
If you turn on a black light, you'll notice
the water fluoresces, and the whole bottle
looks completely supernatural. Now let's go
ahead and put a few spoonfuls of our magical
white powder in a bowl, then try mixing in
small amounts of tonic water to see what happens.
In just a few seconds it becomes amazingly
difficult to stir, because the magic goop
hardens, every time we push on it. With a
little patience, everything should combine,
and behave exactly the way it did before.
The difference this time, is that now it's
fluorescent. If we turn on some black lights,
you can see the magic mud takes on a mystical
glow, and looks and feels a lot like pizza
dough, as long as we move it around constantly.
If you pause for just a second though, the
dough collapses into a glowing goo, and slimes
down between your fingers. But maybe that's
ok, as long as you're in the mood to make
a mess. I tried pouring some out of a flask,
and rather than dropping straight down, you
can see it actually flowed out in a rippled
wave. It's mind blowing to think this stuff
is inside our potatoes, but if you don't feel
like going to all the trouble to get it out,
just use cornstarch instead. It will work
exactly the same. Well know you know how to
turn ordinary potatoes, into a glowing magical
mud, that's non-toxic, easy to make, and even
safe to eat. By the way, you can still eat
the potatoes as well. I tried loading mine
into a waffle iron and made some toasty golden
hash-browns. Well that's it for now. If you
liked this project, perhaps you'll like some
of my others. Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com